[Music]
all right so there are two new things
about this new laptop from Apple the new
color and the new
chip everything that was already great
about the outside of Apple's laptop
redesign is still great you know it
still has a bunch of ports the full
sizee HDMI the mag safe is still here
still has that high quality build the
boxy design the super bright display
also everything that was awkward about
it is also still awkward about it still
has this nice big Notch at the top with
just a webcam and no face unlock but it
comes in Black
now kind of it looked a lot darker in
Apple's announcement video like the
color is literally called space black
right so I'm expecting a really really
black laptop and in the commercial it
looks awesome they talk about this fancy
new anodization process for the aluminum
so it's it's not a coating it's an
actual new chemistry process that is a
part of the anodization itself it's
supposed to be extra fingerprint
resistant but now that we actually have
it here in reality it's I mean it's
darker but like it's still it's just a
little bit darker than the other space
Gray from before if you want to see a
black laptop this is a black laptop like
they make black laptops already so
apples here is just it's a darker gray I
think it's basically the darkest that
Apple could get without showing a ton of
fingerprints I mean it still does show
some fingerprints a little bit it's
definitely not completely immune but
compared to some other black laptops
I've tried it is better than those so
it's somewhere in the middle of not so
many fingerprints but also darker than
normal it's it's fine it's it's darker
which is nice like some some camera
angles it hits it really looks dark but
you get the idea um it also if you're
curious it also comes with black Apple
stickers and it also comes with a black
mag safe charging cable but also that
braided cable is darker than the end and
it also comes with a brick that's still
white so I wouldn't say they fully
committed to the space black theme quite
yet I'll give him partial credit but
then let's talk about the chip inside so
the new 3 animor M3 family of chips gets
announced and it does offer some nice
improvements over the M2 family
definitely it almost feels weird to
compare to the M2 stuff because almost
nobody with an M2 should be upgrading to
this but at least it's a good frame of
reference so I've been testing the
absolute highest end M3 Max in this
laptop which from the M2 Max goes from a
38 core GPU to a 40 core GPU and from 96
gigs of shared memory to now up to 128
gigs CPU wise Apple's claims were about
right you know it's somewhere in the 20
sometimes 30% Improvement range over
last year which is very respectable and
actually it's a bigger jump in single
core performance than I was expecting
which is awesome for you know just the
daily use the quick Snappy everyday
Computing browsing type stuff and then
GPU wise this is where more people were
hoping for a little bit of a bigger
Improvement and again it is a
respectable bump not quite leapfrogging
the big discret gpus but still putting
M3 Max's GPU up at the level of M1 Ultra
so that's pretty impressive and matching
somewhere around AMD Radeon RX 6800 on
benchmarks or about an RTX 3070 which is
you know we're talking a fairly
mid-range card at this point but that's
the thing about all this new GPU
performance and the benchmarks and all
that is great but what's actually more
interesting at least to me is what
you're actually going to do with that
extra performance that extra Graphics
power and for a laptop like this that's
typically games or high-powered Graphics
related applications so yeah when you
see that powerful new GPU in a laptop
with new hardware accelerated Ray
tracing for the first time in a Mac and
the mesh shading and all that probably
the first thing you think is gaming but
then you realize it's a Mac so probably
not gaming but really I think I think
the reason at least in my head that most
people don't associate gaming with Max
is not because they're not powerful I
mean they're they're not as powerful as
the highest end discreet gpus but
they're not bad it's just because the
games that people play and are
enthusiastic about are often not
available on the Mac like I'm not even a
big PC Gamer but you already know if you
want to play The Witcher the new Fallout
Skyrim crisis Apex Legends like there's
a long list and if you want to throw
maximum GPU power at that game to play
it in the best possible quality you're
looking to optimize a PC not buy a Mac
so I actually think and I think it's may
be worth an entire separate video maybe
let me know if you're interested but I
think gaming on the Mac is in an
all-time interesting place right now
because again lots of games are not
available on the Mac but this is the
most powerful Mac that's ever been made
and I've been playing with some of the
games that Apple likes to show off like
in the app store they're like guys we
have games there's lots of games and
they're really good and they're they
take advantage of the new stuff I've
been playing this this game called lies
of PE it's one of the ones I talked
about in the keynote and it takes
advantage of the hardware accelerated
Ray tracing you can see it in the
reflections and on the floor and in the
sword and everything it plays amazing
like it looks great frame rates stay
high I'm playing at 4K resolution
there's a visual depth and and detail
that's beautiful plus Mac OS Sonoma has
the gaming mode which is allocating as
much power as possible to this game it
also lets you use a Bluetooth controller
with way faster sampling and lower
latency and so just maxing out
everything works great it's an awesome
playing experience I was very impressed
I just don't care about this game like
I'm not invested in that particular game
at all it was fun to play the demo and I
was impressed with the actual moment of
the Computing it would get a little warm
and the fans would spin up but the fact
that it would work on those Max settings
is amazing I just don't I'm not invested
in that game at all and I think that
sort of encapsulates the way I feel
about all this extra GPU power is like
you could use it for gaming but if
you're going to buy a computer for this
much money to game you're not buying a
Mac but then again of course this is a
pro uh laptop it's a MacBook Pro and so
there are lots of other non- games that
take advantage of this extra GPU power
and of this new hardware accelerated
rate tracing and the mesh shading and
all that things like Cinema 4D and this
laptop with this ship is better than
ever at all that stuff too and I think
we're actually going to slowly start
seeing even more apps on the Mac take
advantage of this stuff as time goes on
but my conclusion was okay look when the
event happened I watched it and that
last video you can see in that hotel
room and I was very excited about it it
got announced I saw a new matte black
MacBook with a new chip and I thought
that that new color on top of that new
chip would be enough for me to go all
right you know what it's finally time
I'm going to upgrade so I did I clicked
the order button and I purchased a new
maxed out M3 Max MacBook Pro in matte
black but now that I've actually had
this review in it here and I've gone
through my testing and I've experienced
it the color is kind of nice but it's
it's not quite as impressive and new as
I was maybe hoping and then the new chip
is great and everything but it's not
actually going to make a meaningful
difference to my workflow with a couple
of videos I edit on the go on my laptop
from the M1 Max laptop that I've been
using
so I canceled I logged in and I canceled
my order and I will continue to daily
what I have for the past I guess 3 years
now with the M1 Max 16-inch MacBook Pro
turns out it's not for me well I mean I
guess it is a high-end map black laptop
so maybe it is kind of for me but I
think the point I'm trying to make is if
you already have an M family chip
MacBook in the tier that you want
meaning if you have an M2 Pro or an M1
Pro M3 Pro is not going to be the huge
difference for you if you have M2 Max or
M1 Max M3 Max is not really for you this
is like any other spec bump far more for
people with older machines you didn't
need to hear me say this but it's true
for people with older machines with
Intel machines uh or with machines in a
different tier where this would really
unlock something new in their workflow
and that's what's great about them is
you're going to get a better machine
than ever uh for me I'm going to keep
using M1 Max that's a testament to how
good that thing is maybe I'll do a like
a 2 years later 3 years later review or
something like that but for now I'm glad
there's a new darker color available but
yeah you know it's weirdly not for me
still a great laptop still great
displays amazing speakers awesome build
quality battery life still awesome but
maybe my upgrade will come when uh they
really commit to the matte black thing
or there's another huge upgrade
somewhere down the line that's my
conclusion